the father of Nasim Adam told CBS News
his daughter was very upset with YouTube
and he warned police about her her
numerous videos touch on a wide range of
subjects and include parodies police
believe the people she shot were chosen
at random
Mireya Villarreal is at Zuckerberg San
Francisco General Hospital with the
latest on her
Mireya good morning well good morning
all three of the victims that were shot
are recovering here at this South San
Francisco Hospital the male victim is in
critical condition the suspect in this
case though we know seem to hold a
grudge against YouTube and a number of
online complaints she actually said that
she thought her videos were being
targeted unfairly by the company's
filters I'm being discriminated
unfiltered on YouTube and I'm not the
only one in a two-minute YouTube video
now seem out damn complains about the
company's policies
you're not even daddy B - an animal
rights activist and exercise enthusiasts
Adams YouTube hosts included music
videos and exercise routines she had
over 10,000 subscribers on her YouTube
channels all of which have now been
taken down on her personal website she
claimed YouTube tried to reduce her
views and money she earned by applying
age restrictions to some of her videos
like this workout video which prompted
her to call and complain to the company
I contacted some horthy and they also
said the same thing they are some
inappropriate things in your video at
Adams home in Southern California her
father seemed just inside the doorway
said the family is devastated he did not
want to talk on camera but he told CBS
News he reported Ogden missing to police
Monday after she didn't answer her phone
for two days around 2 a.m. Tuesday
police called saying they found her
sleeping in her car in Mountain View
just 30 minutes southeast of YouTube's
headquarters Ogden's father claims he
warned police she was upset with YouTube
and was afraid of what might happen
Mountain View police do confirm they
spoke with Ogden but did not say if her
father warned them that she might head
to the YouTube headquarters we also
reached out to YouTube to ask them about
the complaints that Adam had made we
have yet to hear back from them Beato
likely learned more in the days to come
today a thank you